the international math Olympiad consists
of six problems broken up over 2 days
the three problems given on each day are
supposed to get progressively harder but
on the test from 2011 problem number two
was much more challenging than the
organizers intended for it to be here's
what it states let s be a finite set of
at least two points in the plane assume
that no three points of s are collinear
a windmill is a process that starts with
a line L going through a single point P
and S the line rotates clockwise about
the pivot P until the first time that
that line meets some other point
belonging to S this point Q takes over
as the new pivot and the line now
rotates clockwise around Q until the
next time it meets a point of s this
process continues indefinitely show that
you can choose a point p in s and a line
L going through P such that the
resulting windmill uses each point of s
as a pivot infinitely many times it's a
really beautiful problem and in the full
video we cover a very clever way that
you can solve it